how's gum rosemarys pápai I'm excited
because we're gonna play some more Sims
for the game got updated and now it has
pools here we are back in Nashville what
what am i sealing up the [ __ ] what
happened to my beautiful ass alright so
we can see here we can finally build a
pool an octagon pool that'd be cool get
it is it Ryan
jokes can people swim in that yeah it's
a pool party I want to make it a little
smaller though can people swim in that
can I swim in that swim laps ha ha ha ha
yay this is my baby boo oh my god I look
so happy in it I just love it
in an every way so we have our guy here
Travis Scott he's waiting for bystanders
oh there's one she's doing push-ups of
course friendly direction come swim with
me it will be thing no no no he's
supposed to jump in can he fit what the
[ __ ] hahaha
not you too what do you doing what do
you do you crazy people
alright alright alright alright alright
we need to get the lady out no no
where's it going he's escaping
what are you doing damn it he left oh
he's still there he's still there yes he
he hates me but we're still doing it at
the same time woo right he's out he's
out he's out get out get out get out get
out yes you're in my domain now should
we do a fence maybe like what's more
efficient here something more that says
haha I trapped you [ __ ] i trapped him
in toilets no no where did he go damn it
that sleek son of a [ __ ] fine the
toilet idea may not okay let me let me
see any maybe works it seems like it
works yes i trapped him in toilets
hahaha he's like I should really get
going now thanks ringing out do you bad
you're trapped in toilets I love how you
keep saying I should
get going now well that's just too bad
you should have thought about that
before you got trapped in toilets it
isn't I'm like no I don't like him
is that anaconda what are you doing are
you still alive
Allah he just keeps standing there I
think he's trapped I don't know is he
guarding him
like what's going he's so unhappy about
all these things but he won't move
I mean I've had many great ideas in my
days but this has to be one of the
greatest oh he voluntarily jumped in in
my pool oh you made a big mistake today
buddy
you're in my domain now don't you dare
teleport out yes i trapped you of them
hahahahaha oh my this is like a
minefield oh my god this is the best
idea I've ever had in my life what man
could I possibly get a double trap here
going that would be amazing
what how did he know so he jumped out to
then jump in is he [ __ ] oh my god
who is set him free I demand an answer
yes
all right you thought you could escape
from me huh
Jess I got her oh my god this is like
catching a really good Pokemon so now I
have to at least alright what is he Oh
ironically enough he really has to pee
oh oh oh yes yes yes go in go in go in
don't worry buddy I'm coming after you
no no no no you need you what you want
to swim don't you you want to swim yes
yes look look look at this picture this
is the moment where you realize that you
shouldn't have aw dammit I jumped into
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh it's never felt this
good to trap people with toilets in mine
ah son of a [ __ ] don't you dare
teleport why do you start above silo but
Allah
alright I swear to God if you teleport
let's try sinks maybe sinks are more
effective all right no no no why does ah
all right [ __ ] um you know I [ __ ] him I
don't care if he's my boyfriend you're
going in my toilet trap like I don't
care who you are I don't care about your
status all right we trapped him at least
how's everyone doing here and Ed's in
the swamp in the toilet swamp how's
everyone doing
toilet trapping simulator 2014 my
favorite game of all time No
oh he died all right he died all right
that's good all she died - now why don't
you take a bath take a bath
why don't you yes take a bed remove
everything how you enjoying that bath
now ha ha ha ha ha everyone will see
your penis
oh yeah right he's technically not
blocked in more toilets toilets to the
rescue when in doubt toilets ha ha ha
why not figure this sooner this is ID
you're forced to bathe forever huh hello
he doesn't stop bathing either he's just
keep there's nothing else for him to do
ha ha ha brilliant I press I have to
edit there I hope you bros enjoyed
watching if you did go ahead and hit the
link like that you don't have to do that
mate subscribe come over today and I
will see you brothers in the next one as
always stay awesome bros love you bye